all right y'all
you know how we do let's go
welcome back to your favorite podcast
you know how we do if we
live
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to your favorite podcast
River with Griffin
today we're talking about Britney Spears
man I don't know what's going on with
her
let's see give some thoughts
I just did some shows with Matt Rice in
Atlantic City it was incredible I'll
tell you about that
Rachel's still pregnant
looking thick and I love it
plus some other news and notes but as
always welcome back
[Music]
bye bye
welcome back to real friend with Griffin
excuse me I'm coughing already I
appreciate you being here as always
thank you for watching thank you for
listening uh make sure you hit that
subscribe button subscribe subscribe
subscribe because that's when it's gonna
um you know
I don't know just hit the Subscribe
button y'all
um because that's how you will you know
uh you know see me you know what I mean
wait hold up a second here what's going
on with my why does it look like that
that's so strange oh here we go I need
to do this here we go here we go
um hit the Subscribe button because
that's what you're gonna like
know when I'm on and all that stuff I'm
like I'm like fixing this on the Fly
because it's like I feel I have that
that
OCD compulsion to fix this because I
don't know why this looks like this this
is like
like driving me here we go here we go it
was driving me crazy so I gotta move
this over
[Laughter]
yeah you guys listening like what the
hell is he doing I just wanted to fix my
picture that came on screen but anyways
hit the Subscribe button uh I'm on
Twitch most days watch me Eric Griffin
gaming and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to start doing like custom matches
that means like I could play with fans
and stuff like together so we'll do like
custom Warzone custom multiplayer
matches and I'm gonna start doing those
on Wednesdays after the podcast I'm not
gonna do it today but Wednesdays after
the podcast uh for like the first hour
of my stream it'll be like custom
matches so let's look forward to that so
if you play Warzone you want to get
involved in that make sure you come
check that out and you know you could be
a patreon you could be uh twitch
subscriber to help support the show a
YouTube member or a patreon member
you know I just man I've been out of
town I haven't been able to get to all
my stuff but anyways it's coming trust
me so anyways welcome back to Roofing
with Griffin uh you know you know how we
do if this is your first time you know
you're like is this a comedy book yes
you know what I mean it's like it's it's
everything we do comedy it's fresh off
the cuff off my thoughts that are
happening in live time uh sometimes
we're funny sometimes we're serious but
we're always authentically me and for
the people that have been here before
you know the deal and thank you for
coming
um I want to thank our sponsor for this
show today which is factor factor meals
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with the
chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door
head to factormeals.com Griffin 50 and
use code Griffin 50 to get 50 off
thank you factor
okay guys what's up y'all
thanks for uh being here once again for
everybody that's live on stream right
now I appreciate you
um
yeah you know what I mean uh all the
people that are you know whatever if you
want if you have questions uh you know
let's put up our I'll put up my weekly
uh q a thing right there if you have
some comments and questions uh in the
live chat right now let's go hit me with
that
um you know and I will I'll look at
those periodically throughout the
episode and we'll see what we got and I
can also see the live Chatters right
there and thanks for being here as usual
guys
um
what's going on this week
yes so
this week I was in Atlantic City with my
boy Matt Rife man and my goodness this
kid is famous now I mean
it's like a 4500 Cedar
this theater at Ocean and shout out to
Ocean Casino it was really nice on the
Atlantic City Boardwalk I've been to
Atlantic City a few times sometimes it's
like but this casino was really nice
very new you know how I knew it was new
and modern because in the room you know
how they have like you know you could
plug your plug your USB into the the the
lamp or the radio whatever's right there
they had USBC stuff in there so that let
me know this is new and fresh because
sometimes you're going to a hotel and
you'll still see the old school iPhone
one but like remember the old plug that
was like an inch an inch long they still
got those in some hotels they must be
furious like we paid all this money to
make these uh you know we got like 300
of these things and now we can't even
use them it must be very frustrating to
the hotels that that still have that you
know so yeah so it was a nice hotel
so anyways it was this big theater man
like this big old huge theater
um
let me see I think I have a have a good
picture of it right here
yeah there we go so that's me Matt and
his other his opener Alex his regular
guy
um funny comic as Carrero if I see his
name right I don't know if I said his
name right
anyways check out Alex but um
so anyways yeah so we did five of these
shows and he could have done a six show
so the lady that one of the the social
media person I'm talking to her
backstage while Matt's on stage and
she's like yeah this has been really
incredible no one's ever done this and
he sold out five shows in 25 minutes
five shows 25 minutes okay the kid's
gonna do Radio City Music Hall
six shows already sold out 30
000 tickets in New York City incredible
I had a really great time
I have already I've said this
so many times but I'll say again I'm
super proud of this kid but I'm just
glad that like
I'm glad that I was here
from day one you know so it's like our
relationship is great like I know why
I'm there I support him I'm helping him
he's preparing for a special so I'll
watch his set and then I'll give him
some things like hey there's more meat
on this bone once you try this or that
and then he like works out what he wants
to do so you know we have a great
friendship great working relationship
you know but and I know I know why I'm
there and I'm like this is great he
treats me well he pays me good and
because he's making so much money and I
feel really great that I'm there I love
hearing about all these people who are
like yo man what's up man you know
you're trying to hang out with him now
oh everybody's trying to hang out with
him like where were you where were you
two years ago he's still the same guy
you know what I mean so funny so I like
seeing that
and I'm collecting fans you know like
good for this kid for like because let
me tell you something I'm a monster on
stage okay there ain't too many Comics
that would want me to go ahead of them
at their theater gig because they just
they don't want to work like that but
this kid is like he's cool with it
because he's like these are my fans
they're here to see him we're completely
different he's speaking to them in a way
that they love you know they're they're
like he's like young like them you know
and I'm the you know I'm just I'm just
an old funny guy and it's a great mix
and uh we having a really good I'm
having a great time I'm like I'm ready
to do it all the time with him I love it
you know and it's just again I'm also
like I never performed in front of like
uh that this many people in in five days
before my life and my whole Community
career I realized with me it's like I'm
really funny I'm great on stage but it's
like that's not what gets people to come
I'm still trying to figure out how I can
get people to come watch me do stand up
that's the heart listen that's the whole
business the whole business now is
convincing people to come see you it
used to be you had we had this kind of
like mindset that it was all about being
funny like it's like be funny be funny
be funny and then the people will find
out man people ain't finding out no one
knows they just don't know you know like
look at my little podcast right here I
get four or five thousand uh viewers
here the the other podcast golden hour
those people don't come to my shows they
that has not helped me at all in terms
of stand up that's whatever but it's
great to do that podcast it's great to
like you know have be a podcast host in
front of that large audience and I love
you guys but they're not coming to watch
me perform you know what I mean
listen there ain't too many shows I'm
not gonna be the funniest dude on the
show period just I'm just I'm being 100
about it right now I am
a tremendous comedian okay I love doing
stand up I love sharing my thoughts and
I have fun on stage I laugh at my own
stuff because it's for me and then I
really make sure the crowd has a good
time and sometimes I'm in the mood to
make people think about stuff and then I
find ways to make fun of things that you
don't normally make fun of anyway I'm
not gonna toot my own horn that I'm
tooting my horn right now because I need
to let people know you should come watch
me I'm funny
and speaking of
I will be in
um this weekend I'll be in Kansas City
at the Kansas City comedy club links in
the link you know go to airgriffin.com
uh I have a stuff on Instagram come
check me out there Kansas City Comedy
Club I am there this weekend so come
check me out so anyways really enjoying
uh what you know what it what it was
this weekend it was like so much fun you
know and then we ate well the casino's
treating you well you know and then like
I say the casino people are coming up to
me like damn dude you're like who are
you you're really funny you know what I
mean like because I love that like I
realize again I just realized what is
the thing that holds anybody back in
this business right now the comedy
business is people
convincing people to come check you out
and I guess that would be just like any
restaurant or anything like that but the
difference is like in this businesses
the restaurants let's say if it was food
the restaurants don't want to do any
work like the restaurant like if if the
restaurant business worked like comedy
right now it would be this really
fantastic restaurant with great food and
the restaurant is like yeah but we're
not going to tell anybody about it we're
not gonna like promote We're not gonna
like do anything to like we just want
the food to do it we want people to just
like Word of Mouth like oh that food is
so good and just some people that wonder
why people aren't coming it's because
they're not doing their job you know
like the business right now relies
completely on the artists themselves
their own sort of self-promotion
you know it's like the there's no
reputation for the comedy clubs or
theaters anymore like the comedy club
used to be like they had a reputation in
the community that they were going to
put on a great show like this comedy
club was going to introduce you to a
comedian you've never heard of or a
comedian you have heard of and now
they're like hey look we brought this
guy you like here or this woman you like
or whatever right but for to to capture
new audience we used to rely on the
comedy club the comedy club would be
like they would be promoting in their
area they would have a a a a number list
they would have a call list they would
have emails and they would be like we're
shouting out like hey guys come watch
this guy the comedy clubs don't give a
rat's ass anymore they're just like are
you you got a social media following
we want you to do it you do everything
and then bring people here well like I'm
like not in that I've aged out of that
in a way so it's like trying to figure
out how to get people to come watch me
is the thing so
I'm just gonna focus on that you know
like you I know it sounds crazy like why
haven't you focused on that before
Griffin I know right
you just get caught in your way that oh
oh ways man you know you just it's like
I get so like how many times when I
finish a show at some City and the
people are coming to me after the show
just like whoa I I've never seen you
before I I didn't know you know I didn't
know you were this funny or like oh man
that was really a great time I got you
know I realized I just like if I gotta
get I gotta convince people to come
watch me so I'm telling you all right
now if you've never seen me live you
should come check me out live because
you're gonna have a really good time
I'm hilarious okay
you better ask somebody son but uh
anyways so had a good time with Matt and
like who knows sky's the limit for this
kid man Scott is the limit I should have
like recorded a podcast with him but I
was like ah you know what he's about to
be on Rogue and it's agura and like he's
gonna do all these podcasts and stuff
now because now all of a sudden people
are like oh who's this kid
but I get it it is what it is you know
by the end of the year he will literally
be probably the the most famous comic
in the world it's crazy you know doesn't
mean best just you know he's just really
famous right now and and he's so
Charming on stage really he puts on a
good show that people love him and as
you can imagine it's a lot of women in
the crowd who are just like enamored by
him and and their boyfriends are with
them you know so I mean I have some
funny jokes about it you know because
it's just like so many it's like all
these guys are like what do you want to
be here you know
but by the end of the show Matt wins
them over because he's the in their age
range you know what I mean he's speaking
to them too so then you get the girls
going like oh I'm confused about what
he's talking about then the guys are
like yeah man you know and then by the
end everybody's like together and it's
like a really it's fun to watch so
you gotta uh come check this out check
out Matt Rife and then so look for when
I'm gonna be I'll let you know when I'm
gonna be out of city with him because
that's like you getting more show than
you deserve let me tell you that right
now so fun times on the road with Rife
okay let's go to now uh this week's
comments a bunch of crazy comments this
week uh good ones bad ones crazy ones I
have troll of the week I I actually I
actually uh screenshot this one comment
I'll read you guys and I put it on
Instagram and Twitter because it's it's
so like it's so dumb you know what I
mean like it's so dumb with the the the
the this thought process and I just like
I wanted everybody to see how dumb it
was and per usual I was correct and this
idiot is getting clowned vigorously
anyways uh let me see heavyweight Hank
Eric you're the most funniest I hope
your special guests are involved with uh
oh uh he wants me to be a special guest
with the boys the Workaholics boys uh
they haven't talked to me about it they
do their own thing they don't want me
there if they want to be there I would
be there they don't
um
somebody said carry cat art Bobby Lee
looks like Princess Leia
so stupid
uh let me see what else we got I had
some good ones
oh this one music BH 5 Bo like this this
is one of these ones that I feel like
people forget that this is a podcast you
know like it's like you know what's
going on currently you talk about it
right so this guy wrote great show but
you're falling into the internet trap
regarding lizzo guys the internet trap
just because the internet says she's
she's done doesn't mean she's done it's
it's a few people or non-people on the
Internet her show will sell out and
people will buy her music today we are
you are smarter than that but like I
think that when people write these kind
of comments they they they just want to
write things they don't actually think
it through they don't think it through
they just want to say something to be
like oh you
you know what I mean like bro
that was in the music the the internet
cycle so I talked about it uh and I also
I have my reasons for talking about it
because I just take offense that this
black woman is getting like sandbagged
it just it wouldn't like it's just it's
layered to me the whole thing is layered
what's happening to her but she got
removed from the Super Bowl she got
removed from a lot of different things
man her core fans are probably still
going to be there just like say Louis
CK's fans are still there he won a
Grammy guy won a Grammy right but
there's like levels to like what you
could do I don't know if he's ever gonna
be on TV again or movies or people are
gonna who knows but you can still do
your craft you have your fans right so
I'm just saying she was like this
Enigma she was like just like internet
darling and like you know social justice
Warrior for she was she was a pawn to me
she was she became a political Pawn
about body positivity and all this stuff
and then when it all crashed down just
it you know what I mean I just think
that it's not going to be the same for
her the trajectory that it was on but
anyways the whole point is I was talking
about it because it was in the news
cycle when you lose the Super Bowl you
look do you know what when you perform
at the Super Bowl what it does for you
like they should actually make the
artist pay to be on the Super Bowl as
opposed to like paying them to do it
every single person that does the Super
Bowl Halftime their album sales
skyrockets it does so much for them and
she got removed from that man so that's
like a big deal that's say whatever you
want she took a l in this I don't think
it's gonna be the same but who knows who
knows but anyways like to act like
like just watch the show bruh just be a
passenger because I got it
uh oh here's troll comment of the week
the dumbest comment here they say his
name too Austin beal4879
he writes because the trolls think that
this bugs me you really make your wife
work at Target
so I wrote back I'm gonna read you what
I wrote back
yeah I was like yeah I was like oh you
want your own career and make your own
money and get experience in the career
you want and I was like get in the car
I'm taking you to Target and then I
forced her to interview and then when
she became the visual merchandiser for
the entire store I was like you think
that's it I forced her to use her on her
money on whatever she wanted I said bye
[__] now because I'm a monster like that
that's a funny response in my opinion
once again
these idiot
idiots think
that I am bothered
by the fact that my wife works at Target
I am zero worried about it
shout out to Target thank you for the 15
employee discount
thank you for the free delivery because
she works there
you know thank you for employing her and
letting her she always wanted to be a
visual merchandiser thank you for
letting her do that and when she wants
to move on to a bigger and better thing
or not at all because she might want to
be a stay-at-home mom if she does if she
wants to do that I'm I I support
whatever she wants to do
and the fact that this idiot thinks that
it's an insult
is crazy
people that if anybody worked at a
retail or whatever like that a lot of
times these kind of companies they pay
good there's great Insurance her
insurance is great by the way great
insurance so I don't know
I don't know how to say enough
but again it doesn't matter the trolls
are going to troll I told you about this
one guy he he keeps he keeps sending a
picture of Target workers on anything I
tweet you know that's their life imagine
being that guy that you're following
that closely that you're like well I
gotta put this picture up because that's
gonna get him like
I just don't like
when someone like this makes he don't
realize how he makes women feel as if
women aren't allowed to have Choice make
their own choices and you know work what
they want to work you know this is some
sort of like old feeling you know what
and it's really misogynistic in a way
too of being like you know like I make
her or I let her as if she don't have
her own choices to do whatever she wants
I mean there's a school of thought where
the the old school it's so old school
where men are like well my women women
don't work I don't want my woman to work
I'm taking care like that's that's
whatever that is that's like so archaic
those days are done
but yeah but y'all should go into the
comments and let's say hi you know make
sure you say hi to the troll of the week
congratulations man congratulations
Austin bill4879
yeah I make her work in Target
uh what an idiot oh
neutral of the week this is the second
troll of the week and this is AKA
Boondock 19.
so last week's title was like about I
said it was no loyalty it was to try the
title and then this guy chimes in funny
title considering you showed Bobby Lee
no loyalty in regards to shop
listen
you're not in our friendship you never
will be
trust me everyone involved doesn't care
if you live or die it will do nothing to
our lives
y'all don't know like even after all
that the guy was at my wedding I talked
to him all the time we see him at the
club it's like like y'all don't whatever
my relationship is with these people
one is none of your business
and like you don't really know
everything that has gone on
I that whole situation was dumb
everybody involved was stupid for
letting that be on the internet like
that to me that was just dumb but it's
click bait you know like it got a lot of
views and I got a lot of talk but the
but the the backlash from all the like
the nonsense of having to deal with dumb
comments like this I don't think it was
worth it you know I don't think it was
worth it the whole thing was just stupid
and
you know whatever but like it hasn't
affected it hasn't affected what you
think y'all don't know
about any of this
I know you think you do I know there's
troll websites that you have to go to
you know that that you know can't be on
YouTube and Twitter and all that because
it's so negative so go to Mean Girls go
to meangirls.com where you get all your
information and just live there and that
little Community can just like
laughs we know everything you know like
y'all don't know [__] about [__] man
it's just that
that one pissed me off
just because I'm like anyway it don't
matter piss me off like comedic pissed
me off you know what I mean but I
responded you're so dumb you aren't a
part of our Lives you know so stupid
anyways
um but that was that's gonna be troll of
this week
um
let's see light Knight 3056
I don't I think it was weird names I had
a friend who years ago who's python
escaped from its cage in the garage in
the middle of the night and wrapped
itself all the way around her in her
sleep that that got it they got an offer
in time like
somebody wrote back a liar
snakes aren't pets okay
if you see last week's episode or that I
have the whole there's a section about
this snake that attacked us on snakes on
our pets okay they're not pets you're
actually a monster if you own a snake
you're just like a kidnapper okay you're
just like you took something that is not
supposed to be domesticated or or kept
in a thing like that and you know
you're just you're not you're not a good
person
to to animals doing that
all right
um yeah we're done
we're done with the comments of this
week a lot of negative comments this
week sorry guys
sorry guys but all you know so much
negativity in the world but it is what
it is we're here to talk about it but
you know what you can do to help
yourself as you talk about it is get
some Factor meals guys get some Factor
meals I want to thank Factor who's a big
sponsor of the show it's America's
number one ready to eat meal kit you can
fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian preproof ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door
with the busy fall season just around
the corner you might be looking for a
wholesome convenient meals or jam-packed
or you might have some jam-packed days
you need to get Factor Factor's great
the meals are great it's great portion
control it's great options all different
types of meals vegetarian uh you know
keto whatever the kind of meals you want
to get you can you can really customize
it for yourself and it's great when you
just need something on the go you pop
factor in you're ready to go it's great
Factor's fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
need to do is heat and enjoy and then
back to crushing your goals I told you
there's a there's a really great variety
there's Gourmet plus options treat
yourself to upscale meals with premium
ingredients it's all premium ingredients
you know so check it out man with
Factory you can rest assured you're
making a sustainable choice we offset
100 of our delivery emissions sources
100 renewable electricity for our
production sites and offices and feature
sustainable stores Seafood in our meals
so they're trying to help the
environment as well you know and it's
like the portions you're not wasting
food which is a big deal I hate wasting
food right head to factorymeals.com
griffin50 that's
g-r-i-f-f-i-n-50 and use code Griffin 50
to get 50 off that's code Griffin 50 at
factorymeals.com
griffin50 to get 50 off thank you factor
all right guys
um let's get to some uh let me get just
I don't know if there's any q and A's
but let me like let me go to this real
quick see if anybody uh
see if anybody said anything no wait no
how do I go to this oh here we go I'm so
sorry here we go
all right let's see
how's the car search going I'm not
searching for a car oh I'm glad you
brought this up I'm not searching for a
car already got a car I'm getting the
Fisker ocean I ordered it a year ago you
know you had to put five thousand down
well no you got 250 for the the 250 for
the like the reservation and then it was
like you wanted to be one of the first
five thousand to get it
and it's a special version of the car so
I put 5000 for that and I'm ready to
you know so what I did the other day was
I was like where the hell is my car
because I've seen people get cars and
here's the thing too is I wanted to get
a rivian
I wanted to get a rivian but when I was
on the website and everything it was
like they didn't know when they were
going to be released and there was all
this like you know stuff about they were
losing Google got rid of it was like a
whole thing about Riven I didn't know
what was going to happen and I wanted
the SUV version and I was like you
didn't know when you were gonna get it
or when it was going to be delivered and
so and it was like wait it was way more
expensive but still I wanted a review
and I don't think I could get it now I'm
looking on the street and it's a bunch
of rivians on the street have you seen
them the SUV version of the rivian oh
man it's great I love that version of
the car man
okay let's go to the website and I'll
show you guys what I'm talking about I
want to get this rs1 rivian right so
um yeah here it is right here this is
perfect we can go right to it you know
this is crazy look at me nope that's not
it here we go boom so yeah I wanted to
get this right here right
you know and that that looks dope and
it's all electric the features are great
but again I didn't think I could get it
so then I I read up about this company
Fisker and I was like oh you know what
and I like what they're talking about in
Fisker how like it's like all
sustainable energy sources of getting
everything and
recycled stuff for the leather and you
know they really are trying to limit
their carbon footprint and they have
like this whole thing about you could
see all everything you could see their
carbon front vent they're trying to be
transparent about how the car is made
where the car is made like they didn't
build their own Factory and like so you
know all the emissions that comes with
that and all the resources wasted for
that they're using a factory that
already makes like BMWs and and fancy
cars in Austria they're using that
company to to make the car and then and
that's why the the cost for this car
isn't as high as the other cars I mean
it's still expensive it's a 70 000 car
when you get all the trimmings and stuff
that I'm getting but it's like you know
some of these cars like the Escalade
that's about to come out as a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars they have an
electric Escalade coming out right so
you know I want and so I I said you know
what let me
um
I was like let me freaking
let me let me hit them up on Instagram
so I went on like a little Instagram
thing man I was like where's my car dude
you know so here's the Fisker website
you know so it's like
you know
that you could configure it on the
website it's great man and so as I
looked at this and I was like oh I
really like what's going on with this
and then they have the they're coming
out with an affordable version of it
they're coming out with a truck that's
Alaska you know but uh then it coming
out but of course they have a really
fancy seven that goes 700 miles but I
think it's like super expensive that car
but anyways I went on an internet Blitz
to get my car because I was like I hit
them up I I made a bunch of comments on
their videos I was like on their thing I
was like yo where's my car I went to
Henry Fisker the owner of the company I
was like yo man can I get my car
you know like I was like can I get it
and then I like put up a story up well
they hit me up they hit me up and then
someone called me and they were very
nice they were like hey Eric uh let me
just let me give me your order number I
gave them my order number they were like
this is exactly where your car is and
when you're gonna get it so I was like
yes so it should be mid-september I
should have my new Fisker ocean I can't
wait to drive it and uh you know anyways
and then all right so next comment what
do you think of Oppenheimer I haven't
watched Oppenheimer I actually have no
desire to watch it that's just my thing
it's like I think that what that movie's
about was terrible and I don't know why
we're you know hyping that up I don't
care what they tried to show in the
movie about like oh we knew we did
something wrong whatever it's still like
man
what a slap in the face to the people
that we dropped bombs on but anyways uh
uh no let's see a lot of silly questions
I'll get back to this later we're good
uh
let's see we'll just get back to the
live chat so there we go all right so
today's big today's uh episode uh one of
the things I wanted to talk about in
today's episode is
Britney Spears
wait do I have it what's going on here
hello
why is this showing up
you don't have to do like this and come
back there we go
okay y'all
let's talk about Britney Spears
you guys like what am I doing talking
about Britney Spears well I'll tell you
you know this really seems
like two things could possibly be true
at the same time
two things could be two at the same time
Britney Spears needed to be in a
conservative ship
and her family were taking advantage of
her
like it's not one they don't need to
they're not mutually exclusive
okay what business of it is ours she was
super famous Britney Spears is one of
the most famous people on the planet at
a certain time and so now when you see
her now it's kind of sad
but I don't know if it should be sad if
you understand what I mean like should
we be are we only are we sad about what
we see with Britney Spears because we
know about the conservatorship and
everything that was going on and then
her like weird ranting and ravings on
the internet like she can't even make an
omelet on the internet without people
being concerned about her so she was
like doing this cooking video she's
making an omelette and she's like not
scrambling the eggs she's not taking the
seeds after uh bell peppers and just
kind of doing a I thought I thought
kitchen with Griffin was weird this
seems to be you know people are like you
know every video she does on the
internet there's like some sort of like
concern for her safety and all this kind
of stuff and then you know and then of
course she's getting divorced from her
husband so they were like together
apparently for like six years I don't
know like
why did you start how did that even come
about not that Britney Spears doesn't
deserve love or anything like that but
that must have been very difficult for
her to be like in a conservatorship
where she can't even get off birth
control you know like if she wanted to
have a kid they wouldn't allow it like
apparently the rules of this
conservatorship was like like really
it's the strong I don't know and so
how'd you even meet this guy and then
they you know this guy seems like I I
don't understand this guy's intentions
and motivations right
but because of the craziness of the
whole thing you can only speculate and I
think part I'm trying to be delegated
because I feel like that sucks
but you know it's like but then you find
out that there's like the uh
prenup agreement was like air air type
prenup where he gets nothing so you go
okay well he didn't do it for the money
right but what did he do it for I mean
did he really love her I don't know it's
like it's so strange to see all the
things that have gone on with poor
Britney Spears man you know and it's
like
the the there's all these reports about
The deterioration of their relationship
you know and then you know they're
coming out and saying they don't know
the exact reasons of their split they're
saying she cheated you know it's like
what is going on but like the thing that
really like when you see the thing that
was really like uh oh what's going on
with Britney Spears is when you see like
this picture that I have of everything
right now like she's on Instagram I feel
like and I I heard I read too that she
hasn't even seen her kids like they
don't let the kids hang out with her
they haven't seen her in a year or
whatever it is like that it's like man
I hope those kids are okay because it
must be tough if your mom is Britney
Spears even if your mom was a hundred
percent
I don't want to say normal but you know
what I mean let's say she was just like
regular ass mom but she was Britney
Spears that's still got to be tough for
your kids you're 15 years old and your
mom's Britney Spears you know
all your friends are like oops I did it
again you know what I mean like all your
friends know about your mom and then
like and like young people Britney's
played out like Britney's not famous
anymore because this is the real thing
too she ain't famous like she was famous
it just happens like that people young
kids today they age out of that stuff so
now Britney's 40 something she's not
someone that the young girls are like oh
I want to be like Britney Spears now all
they see is a crazy chick online pole
dancing you know
they see a mom
provocatively dancing on Instagram and
you're just kind of like wait what is
this what's going on so it's just all
this information that we don't know you
have to decide for through and you just
see that you just go what the hell is
this right like her husband Sam after
six years of love and commitment to each
other my wife and I have decided to end
our journey together we will hold on to
the love and respect we have for each
other and I wish her the best always
[__] happens asking for privacy seems
ridiculous so I will just ask for
everyone including media to be kind and
thoughtful I am now trying to be kind
and thoughtful
so
yeah I just it's it it it is something
else man but like like this is the thing
that really you know
you know you you see this man
you know what I mean and you're just
kind of like wait what's going on uh
Britney
like where's uh wait how come you can't
see this full screen
I don't understand why this isn't coming
in full screen
okay here we go
like when you
you know what I mean like I don't know
if this is if is she trolling us
you know
like is she trolling
yeah I mean like
what's she doing y'all
like
I think that we're gonna look back on
the things that we posted on the
internet all of us no matter who we are
and we might be like what was this well
why did why did we do this
and like she's like playing music you
know
and it's just like this isn't even the
one like I mean I guess like this is
what you would think like you're like
her kids
let's say you inviting friends over and
then you come into the other room you
walk into your room and your mom is
doing an Instagram video like this
playing her music in the background and
you just kind of like all right so
there's like two schools of talk thought
you know there's people out there who
are like go get it girl oh Britney still
got it hey you know and then there's
other people who might be like oh my God
this is so sad but it's like I don't
know how you feel you tell me
how you feel you know and it's just like
that's the thing too about it I think
that what I'm saying is all the news and
notes about her it's crazy like this
one's nothing this is like a real just
like you know this is somebody having a
good time right but there's another one
where she's like pole dancing and it's
like very like super provocative where
you you go am I concerned about it
because I know about the conservative
ship and and all the craziness all the
crazy ranting and raving that she does
and we see this are we going to be
concerned are we should we be concerned
at all I mean is it you know you know
what I'm saying like it's such a weird
it's such a weird thing I mean this
chick was so famous since she was 18
years old so famous Oops I did it again
and all that stuff and now we're seeing
this version of her we're just kind of
like what like I don't know how to feel
you know some of you are just like let
me see comments
um
some people like oh man relax she's just
having fun man she just loves dancing
that's her expressing herself that's
somebody says that you know that's a
attitude
uh
uh you know and other people might be
like
you know it's like what the hell are you
doing chick
I don't know you know what I mean
you know I'm talking about it on my
podcast because you know she's famous
it's in a new cycle there's always
something going on with her you know
what I mean like just pictures that I
have behind me right now is one of the
ones that was just kind of like whoa
what are you doing you know it's just
like this sort of like maybe my thing is
like don't give it away for free girl
get on uh get on get on only fans and
and get you some money for this right I
don't know
you know what I mean but it it just is
like
[Laughter]
this is on Instagram
oh no
man it's just
again we're gonna look back
you know we're gonna be like when we
were single and just having fun and all
the things we would say and do and then
you become a father you become a mother
you become you know and then you start
to go oh man I don't know if I should
have done that but like we did these
things right but now we're documenting
these things you know like we're
documenting them and we have them online
for the world to see later
uh
uh this is like
man I don't even know what I'm saying
guys you know if you're listening at
home right now on screen is like I'm
showing some of her videos that she has
up and one of them is just like crazy
pole dance that she's doing
like let's say you don't know who this
is if this wasn't Britney Spears and you
saw some lady doing this on Instagram
what would your thoughts be like it's
you know like it's I don't know like is
he is she trolling Us by doing this or
is she disturbed we don't know that's
what makes it that's what makes it the
Enigma of it that's what's so weird
about it because we don't really know
what's happening we can't unknow the
information that we know we know it's
like oh well she was
in a conservatorship
you know she had that crazy rant in
court you know we we know all these
things that have happened to her all the
you know the ball of the shaved head
we know she needed help right we don't
know if she got the help she needed in
that 13 years of the conservative ship
we don't know if she got help and now
when she's free to do whatever she wants
she's doing this
so I don't know
if she needs help or if she's just like
uh you know maybe she's just patrolling
us and playing this or is there
somewhere in the middle
it's definitely to me odd behavior
you know
so I don't know
I don't know guys
um you know you tell me
you know what I mean you tell me what
you think about crazy ass Britney Spears
all right let's get to some other topics
right now thank you Brittany for being
uh weird in the news so I can talk about
something on Roofing with Griffin on my
weekly broadcast that I need content for
yeah I mean why is this I don't know why
this is It's not
I can't it's not switching
um
you know I don't know why it's not
what is going on
I already got oh wait wait wait wait I'm
gonna put this
all right here we go here we go here we
go
that doesn't make any sense
all right I went to that screen oh here
we go
why he's doing that anyways all right so
some weird stories of you know let's go
my Instagram stories of the week so yeah
man
turns out the Flash
uh biggest Financial loss for a
superhero movie ever turns out they lost
somewhere between 200 million dollars on
the movie
man
so if you're a fan of The Flash people
were like Oh I thought it was a good
movie I thought it was good you know
it's like
what does this mean for the DC Universe
what does this mean for James Gunn
moving forward because as I said before
he endorsed this movie
I don't think he I don't believe him now
I don't believe him
they made this movie they kept pushing
it back because of the dude's troubles
James Gunn takes over he watches it and
I'm sure he watched it and was like oh
no
but then he put out the statement create
a superhero movie I've ever seen you
know like he said that but now we know I
think he just said that to because he's
being a company man but it's like damn
man damn
why do you think this movie failed you
know I'd love to see in your comments do
you think do you think it just wasn't a
good movie uh do you think it really is
about this the guy himself and all his
off camera troubles or or what do you
think it is are we done with superhero
movies is that what it is or what do you
think you know what was your reason I
would love to hear
what you guys think about it but man
to me they should have just put it out
the guy's troubles are not who cares if
especially if if you know you've spent
this amount of money and it's gonna be a
like we we can't lose this amount of
money we can't put 400 million dollars
into a movie in terms of like the budget
of the movie and the and the um the
press for the movie we can't put three
400 million dollars and just write it
off as nothing we gotta put this movie
out you already know you're gonna make
that choice just put it out just put it
out they should have just put it out
when they planned on putting it out and
then you know deal with like the
repercussions of that I think more
people would have saw the movie because
of all the stuff people were talking
about him they just oh let's go see well
you know that's just how it works so
that was that was kind of sad you're
just you know for him and like you know
whatever I just I thought it was the
movie was I did a review of it make sure
you check out that episode
um YouTube is working on a multi-view
feature allowing users to watch four
things at once are you kidding me people
already don't have attention span to
watch one thing so now it's gonna be
four things on your screen what does the
uh wow what are we doing to ourselves
that seems to me that's like sensory
overload and imagine having four things
on the screen are you gonna watch four
podcasts at once if you do make sure one
of them's different with Griffin
so I don't know I saw this and I was
like this was really weird and I got
this from one of my favorite sites on uh
Instagram which is pubity I I don't even
know how you say it but it's p-u-b-i-t-y
that's one of my favorite websites
Instagram accounts to follow they always
have some real interesting stories on
there so make sure you give them a
follow
other story now this is the one I really
wanted to talk about
dying wife asks husband can I have sex
with my ex one last time
damn
what would you do
your wife's about to die she got a
terminal illness she's going to die and
she comes to you and says can I have sex
with my ex one last time
the news report that had come out if it
was me is
I would have been on Instagram I'm sad
to announce
my wife died early from complications
from her illness
you know what I mean we supposed to do
what would you do
I guess I feel like I'm the kind of
person that just
I don't even know man this is tough I
mean this is actually really tough if
you really think about it what would you
really truly do you know it's like if
you're a good person I guess you just go
go ride it go ahead honey you know but
then it's like I don't know you might
want to be like because you're going to
question your whole relationship you're
gonna doubt everything you're gonna say
You're Gonna think it's about you you're
gonna think like oh man as opposed to
like this chick is dying first of all
the person you end up with how about
this the person that you are most
compatible with to being a long-term
relationship does not mean that's the
person that you have you've had the
greatest sex with in your in your life
sometimes the greatest sex could be that
crazy night you had in Mexico after on
our on a cruise ship that you met this
crate you know what I mean crazy person
and y'all connected and it was just one
of those nights and the circumstances of
the thing was just magical or you know
or you hear about an abusive
relationship and the only way they were
able to really communicate with each
other is having like makeup sex and it
was just like this sort of passionate
sex but everything else in a
relationship was trash so you maybe it's
that person that that you know you know
what I mean
so I just
I don't know honestly I don't know how I
don't know how I would feel I don't know
if I like what do you how are you not
gonna allow this like you go because now
you made it like it's gonna be
uncomfortable in the last days of her
life anyway so the last moments of your
you know the last days of your wife's
life weeks whatever you said I don't I'm
not comfortable with that now you but
you know she's told you this what are
you supposed to do right then if you let
her do it and when she comes back what
are you just gonna be like well I hope
that was good you know I hope you
enjoyed that you know what I mean like
what are you supposed to do you know
maybe I'd let my wife go she would go do
that but when she came back there'd be
three hookers
in the kitchen you know what I mean
just I don't know I'd have a stripper
pole I'd have Britney Spears stripper
pole in the living room and just three
hookers in there just kind of like hey
what's up how you doing yeah he's you
know always wanted to do this you know
you know I don't know it's just like
what are you gonna do you're gonna call
your exes and be like because like I
don't know if
how about this scenario
your wife says can I have sex with my ex
you let her go do it she comes back
she's had the sex you're dealing with
the shame of it doctor calls
hey we found a cure
we actually have a way to to extend her
life for years all right
she don't get the call
let's let's make this more dark your
wife goes has sex with her ex
she comes back she's like
yeah yeah
it was good thank you for letting me do
that baby but the doctor called while
she was gone and the doctor's like
yeah we we actually can extend our life
five years
do you tell your wife
you know what I mean
your wife comes in the door glowing
you're on the phone with the doctor
you're you know what I mean you're on
the phone with the doctor you know and
she comes in the door looking just like
I am every woman and she just looked
like glowing like she just had she just
got dick down doctors like we can extend
her life five years and you're like this
thank you
hey babe how was it
She Gotta Go you ain't living five more
years with that knowledge you you you
going that's what I'm doing
hahaha
uh you guys tell me oh [__] sorry oh I
messed up the thing
all right
um oh well that's what I wanted to talk
about anyway
uh oh man I'm running out of time I'm on
a plane
and I was watching Renfield I saw
Renfield with Nick Cage Nick Cage and uh
what's the kid's name Robert Kirkman
um oh no no that's the no no no Nicholas
Holt that's the guy's name I see him in
a bunch of things he's always in this
weird movies and Aquafina was in it guys
I saw this on an airplane right I
thought it was just gonna be a dumb Nick
Cage movie this was actually I really
enjoyed this movie man I'm actually I
actually recommend you going to see
Renfield you know Nicholas Cage is
actually a really great actor and I
believed him as this sort of outlandish
Dracula character he played it just
right he played it just right so I do
recommend uh Renfield if you can rent it
right now or you could probably see it
for free on one of the streaming
services it's actually a good watch I'm
not mad at it okay that's what I'll say
about it I saw it I thought it was gonna
be ridiculous
and when I watched it I was like you
know what this ain't bad
so
um yeah it's like you know through the
story of renfield's eyes you know and
Renfield was like you know Dracula's
familiar and he had sort of Dracula's a
little bit of Dracula's power so he
stayed alive but he had to serve Dracula
and he had to eat bugs that's the way he
survived right but this kid always plays
the things great Aquafina was like she
was just everybody I thought was like
fine everything was fine and it made for
a good movie so I do recommend this
movie and I give it like eight woo-woos
foreign
other thing I wanted to talk about real
quick because we're ending it is the new
season of The Witcher now I'll say this
man this sucker is boring man it is so
boring the first like I think there's
eight episodes eight or ten episodes I I
think like the first six episodes are
boring as hell I didn't care what was
happening I didn't care about what like
why are they doing this but I will say
the last few episodes got me interested
again I stuck it through and the last
few episodes were like
all right this is cool I think the
witcher's worth watching type of thing
but I don't know I mean you may not last
like to me if something's gonna be
boring because they like uh you know
giving a lot of subtext a lot of like uh
to lead up to it you know they got to
give you all this backstory and all this
kind of stuff and so you're just kind of
like oh man usually you got to get that
done in like three episodes in my
opinion
three episodes you gotta get that done
and then all right this about to start
getting good this took like six six
episodes before I was like uh okay I
guess I can watch like what is happening
with this you know so I don't know
um
y'all got to check that out I'm not even
gonna give it any woo-woos because it's
a TV show and I I gotta think about it
you know I I don't know guys it just
like I say this was a weird show
he's like by the way the performances
are fun everybody's great this lead
actress is beautiful I think she does a
great job playing yennefer as her name
Freya Allen and Anya uh Charlotte both
these women are very beautiful and
they're great actresses very the
physicality in the show is great uh
what's his name Henry Cavill I always
call him cavizel Henry old old school
old Superman he's great you know but
I don't know I just again I'm really I'm
this is a mixed review of The Witcher
like I say first half
just you don't care that's the best way
I can describe it but I will say this
if you stick it through you're gonna be
okay with it you're gonna be like all
right I'm like I'm gonna watch the next
season how about that if it comes out
again I'm invested still I just wish
they would have done the Lolita better
than they did okay I'll say that all
right
all right guys uh thanks for watching
another episode of riffing with Griffin
uh as always please subscribe to the
show Please Subscribe hit your
notifications so you know when I go live
on Wednesdays and I'm putting way more
stand-up Clips up I have a stand-up clip
I'm gonna put up from uh my shows with
Matt in uh in a in in Atlantic City hit
me up on Twitch man I'll be on Twitch in
like 10-15 minutes so check me out there
if you want to be a subscribe there if
you want to help support the show or
subscribe on patreon to help support the
show too either way any one of those
ways is great or be a YouTube member on
either one of the the Eric and I'm on uh
Eric Griffin gaming on YouTube as well
guys well you know what time it is y'all
how we do it every single week
oh yeah
with that rap recap
oh it's Eric
always riffing
never skip it for a good time while I
hit these Rhymes Britney Spears look
crazy
Daisy
it's kind of hazy
maybe this episode is lazy
but it don't phase me keep your comments
coming
troll
go dig a hole jump in
whoa Eric Griffin with the Wind
[Music]
once again it's Eric Griffin here on
Griffin with Griffin I see you again
next week
dancing move that feet